شكرا لمحمد اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى
هذه الساعه الاخباريه المفصله نخصص معظمها
لتطورات المشهد السوداني ونبدا بالعناوين
خلينا بنقول بروايه او بادراك الطرفين
لخطوره الوضع في لقاء خاص مع العربيه
المبعوث الامميه للسوداني يؤكد العمل على
وقف اطلاق النار قبل التفاوض
قوه الدعم تتهم الجيش السوداني بعدم
الالتزام بالهدنه والجيش يعلن احباط
تحركات للدعم غرب الخرطوم
الامم المتحده تحذر من سوء الوضع الانساني
بالسودان وتقول انه يتجه لكارثه شامله
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
السلطات الفرنسيه تعتقل العشرات بعد
اشتباكات مع محتجين وتقول ان مئه وثمانيه
من عناصر الامن اصيبوا بالمواجهات
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان الهدوء النسبيه الذي شهدته
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم قد بدا
بالتلاشي فقد تجددت الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوه الدعم السريعه في مناطق
متفرقه من الخرطوم وبحري وسط تحليق كثيف
للطيران وفي اطار المساعي الاقليميه
والدوليه لتثبيت الهدنه اختص المبعوث
الاماميه الى السودان فولكربرت العربيه
بلقاء اكد فيه موافقه طرفين على اجراء
محادثات البيت الابيض بدوره حذر من امتداد
القتال في السودان الى دول الجوار مؤكدا
ان واشنطن تركز حاليا على تمديد الهدنه
وجعلها دائمه
لازم اشتغل يعني في في الظروف
سلعه في زياده اي حاجه زايده لازم انا
اشتغل
لي
ساعتين ثلاثه وقف لانه البلد ما امنه
بقى صعب
خاطر بنفسه يحاول يستغل القواد ما حبابه
والخوف ما منه فايده
[موسيقى]
في حديث خاص للعربيه اذا قال المبعوث
الامميه للسودان فولكربس قال ان العمل جار
لوضع التفاصيل اللوجستيه لمفاوضات السودان
مع الامريكيين والسعوديين ورجح ان تجري
مفاوضات الحل في السعوديه مشيرا الى ان
الاولويه الان لوقف اطلاق النار اكد
المبعوث الامامي ان طرفي صراع ادركا خطوره
الوضع ووافقا على محادثات فنيه للوصول الى
وقف لاطلاق النار
شددس على ان الحديث الان منصب على تمهيد
الارضيه لوقف اطلاق النار اولا وصولا في
مرحله لاحقه للتفاوض وانا ما بحكي هلا عن
تفوت سياسي انا بحكي عن محادثات حول حلول
فنيه الى هذه الماء
لانشاء وتاسيس اليه
لوقف اطلاق نار دائم وثابت مع اليه مراقبه
والتحكم على وقفك لكنر
حصلنا على وقفه لاك نار ثابت
فبالتاكيد نعود الى مساله الترتيبات
السياسيه انه
مساله
تشكيل حكومه مثلا
هي مساله ستكون مطروحه
فورا بعد وقفه لكنها
بالتاكيد كل السودانيين ايضا راي في
بالتاكيد الوضع
سيختاش بعدين الى
الى بدايه جديده
للعمليه السياسيه
فالمقابل اكد الرئيس الكينيه ويليام روتو
ان طرفي صراع في السودان رفضا الاستجابه
لدعوات ايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي والمجتمع
الدولي لوقف اطلاق النار واضاف خلال
اجتماع مع مسؤولين افارقه وامميين ان
الازمه الانسانيه في السودان وصلت الى
مستويات كارثيه وسط نقصد في المياه
والغذاء والادويه مشيرا الى ان عدد
النازحين مستمر في الارتفاع مع فرار
المزيد الى دول الجوار
ميدانيا اتهم الدعم السريع الجيش السوداني
بتحويل مستشفى السلاح الطبي باندرمان الى
منصه للقصف المدفعي واشار في بيانا له الى
ان القصف المدفعيه العشوائي من مستشفى
السلاح الطبي ادى لمقتل واصابه كوادر طبيه
بحسب تاكيدات الدعم السريع واضاف ايضا ان
طيران الجيش لا يزال يحلق في سماء الخرطوم
ويقصف احياء سكانيا
[تصفيق]
كان الجيش السوداني قد اكد في بيان له ان
قوات الدعم السريع حشدت اكثر من 65 الف
عنصر والفين مركبه للهجومي على الخرطوم
قبل 15 من ابريل لكن الجيش استطاع التصدي
لمحاولات انتشارهم مشيرا الى ان الجيش
تمكن في غضون اسبوعين من القتال ان يخفض
قدرات الدعم السريعه القتاليه الى النصف
مضيفا انه تم احباطه عده تحركات لتعزيزات
عسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع قادمه من اتجاه
الغرب الى الخرطوم
بعد ان كانت نواه الحراك الشعبيه الذي
اطاحها بنظام الرئيس السابق عمر البشير
تحولت مدينه عطبره الى قبله للهاربين من
هول الصراع الدائر بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريعه
[موسيقى]
معنا في الاستوديو مديره مكتب العربيه في
السودان لنا يعقوب اهلا بك معنا لينا مره
جديده كيف يمكن وصف هذا اليوم من ايام
الصراع على صعيد السودان ككل بين الطرفين
نزاع مساء الخير طاهر اليوم هناك اشتباكات
في مناطق متفرقه كان يوم امس هادئ نسبيا
بعد اعلان الهدنه ولكن اليوم كان هناك
اشتباكات في بحر ام درمان الخرطوم كان
هناك تمشيط وتحليق للطائرات فوق عدد من
المناطق والاحياء السكنيه في مناطق شهدت
اشتباكات باسلحه خفيفه في مناطق اخرى سمع
عدوي انفجارات وكذلك
مدافع طائرات مضادات طائرات كان هناك
اشتباك باسلحه ثقيله في بعض المناطق كان
هناك قصف ايضا الشرق النيل كافوري بعض
المناطق في بحري يعني كانت فيها كثير من
الاشتباكات اليوم كذلك في غرب ام درمان
وفي بعض المناطق كذلك في محيط القياده
العامه في وفي قصه الخرطوم بعض الاحياء في
العاصمه الخرطوم لذلك ننكر ان نقول ان يوم
ان هذا اليوم كان من حيث الاشتباكات
الاعلى والاقوى بعد اعلان هدنه بين
الطرفين طبعا الهدنه لم يلتزم بها سواء
كان الجيش او الدعم السريع وكان واضح ذلك
من سماع الاشتباكات والاصوات الرصاص في
كثير من الاحياء كان نتائج لهذه
الاشتباكات الان هل غيرت شيئا في المعادله
او انه لا يزال عنصر عدم الحسم لاي طرف من
الطرفين هو سيد الموقف لا لا يزال عدم
الحسم واضح بالنسبه للمواطن السوداني
الامر مختلف للبيانات التي تصدر من الجيش
والدعم السريع طبعا كلا الطرفين يشيران
الى تقدم القوات المسلحه تقدمت فعلا في
مناطق كذلك الدعم السريع تمدد في بعض
الاحياء السكنيه والشوارع لا يمكن ان نقول
ان هناك طرف حسم هذا الصراع رغم ان كل
البيان وكل طرف يعلن انه تقدم وانه اوشك
على حسب هذه المعركه طيب الناس الان ماذا
يفعلون يعني ما الذي باستطاعتهم ان يفعلوه
في خلال ايام النهار مثلا بعيدا عن ساعات
الليل هل هناك ساعات يستطيعون فيها الخروج
لتلبيه احتياجاتهم وهل لا يزالون قادرين
على
الاجلاء من مناطقهم ومنازلهم اذا ارادوا
مثلا اليوم كان هناك قلق امس شاهدت كثير
من مقاطع الفيديو تحدثت مع كثير من
المواطنين في المناطق المختلفه كانت هناك
حركه وهناك نوع من محاوله استعاده الحياه
التسوق اخذ حاجياتهم كثير من الافراد
حاولوا ان يملاوا الوقود في سياراتهم كان
هناك نوع من الحركه حتى ان بعضهم كان
يحاول العبور من ام درمان الى الخرطوم لكن
اليوم مع هذه الاشتباكات المتفرقه مع
التحليق الطائرات مع القلق الذي انتبا
كثير من السكان في هذه المناطق الثلاث كان
هناك قلق من العوده مره اخرى الى ممارسه
الحياه بالتالي هم حينما
تنخفض هذه الاصوات اصوات الاشتباكات
والرصاص والطائرات ومضادات الطائرات
والاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه يكون هناك نوع
من الارتياح ومحاوله
لممارسه الحياه اما اليوم يبدو ان الوضع
مختلف بحسب كثير مما تحدثنا اليهم وبحسب
طبعا حتى مراسلوا العربيه وكذلك كثير من
الصحفيين المتعاونين ووكالات الانباء التي
اشارت لهذا الامر يعني محلات البقاله
محطات البنزين الافران صيدليات الى ما
هنالك يعني تفتح بحسب الظروف في المعركه
بالضبط تفتح وتقتل تفتح وتقتل بالضبط نعم
وهناك وعندها حاجياتها متوفره او ليس جميع
السوبر ماركتات او الصيدليات لاننا نعلم
ان الامداد الى هذه المحال او الصيدليات
او الاسواق تعتمد بصوره مباشره على
امكانيه الحركه على توفر الوقود على امان
الشارع بالتالي هناك بعض البقالات
الصغيرات تحاول ان تلبي حاجياتها من
المخزون الذي لديها اما فكره الامداد من
الشركات خاصه كثير من الشركات التي اعلنت
عن نهب لمحتوياتها والسرقه تمت لشركاتها
هذا الامر ايضا يؤثر بصوره واضحه على
امداد هذه الشركات لكثير من التجاريه يعني
اقرا الخبر العاجل الان عن مصادرنا قبل ان
يعني اقف على كيف تستقبلينه كمدير لمكتبنا
في السودان ترى الصراع في الجنينه بدرفور
يوقعان على وثيقه لوقف الاعمال العدائيه
كيف يمكن ان تستقبلي معنا مثل هذا الخبر
كيف تفهميه يمكن هذا ان يفسر بانه في
الحقيقه خبر جيد الدارفور لا ينقصها اي
نوع من الاشتعال لا ينقصها اي نوع من
الحروب في السابق حينما كانت الدوله
مستقره نسبيا كانت ترسل او يرسل الجيش
تعزيزات عسكريه كان هناك تعزيز امني من
ولايات دارفور يذهب الى المنطقه الملتهبه
الان الوضع يختلف لا احد يستطيع ان يساعد
دارفور بارسال اي قوات الى هناك لان
التركيز مصفي الخرطوم حينما تحاول هذه
القبائل مع بعضها بعض ان تحل هذه الخلافات
وان يكون هناك وسطاء من هذه المدينه بلا
شك انه امر يحسب على الاقل لمن قاموا بهذا
العمل ومن شانه ان يسهم في تقليل حده
التوتر الدائري في كيف يمكن ان نربط بينما
يحصل في الخرطوم وما كان يحصل في الجنينه
في دارفور الجيش السوداني اشار في وقت
السابق الى ان الدعم السريع حاول ان يشعل
هذه المنطقه بمحاوله بافتعال بعض المعارك
القبليه هناك حتى ينجر الجيش للتدخل دائما
ما اقول ان ما يحدث في الخرطوم لا علاقه
له حتى اللحظه بدرفور حتى ان حدث في احدى
المناطق ما يحدث في الخرطوم مختلف تماما
الجيش السوداني الان يحارب قوات الدعم
السريع يعتبر ان هذه القوات تمردت عليه في
الخرطوم وحاولت دخول الخرطوم من اطراف
الخرطوم للسيطره والانقلاب على البرهان
وعلى الجيش السوداني هذا امر ربما عززته
بعض المعلومات الوارده كثير من وكالات
الانباء حتى الامريكيه التي تحدثت عن
تقارير سابقه لهذا الام الوضع في الخرطوم
هو الصراع حتى اللحظه بين الجيش والدعب
السريع حاولت كثير من الجهات استغلاله بما
فيها حتى النظام السابق ولاحظنا ان كثير
من الاصوات التي بدات تعلو الان ولكن اصل
هذه المشكله هو هي مشكله عسكريه تتمثل في
تقدم الدعم السريع في مواقع الجيش
السوداني ثم بعد ذلك هذا الرفض وحدث هذا
الصراع العسكري بعد حدوث هذا الصراع اتوقع
ان تكون هنا يكون هناك صراعات في دارفور
نتوقع ان يظهر كثير من رموز النظام السابق
نتوقع ان تشتعل بعض المناطق كثير من
الجهات التي تحاول استغلال هذا السبب
لتحقيق عندما شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
المعلومات والشروحات لنا اليعقوب مديره
مكتب العربيه في السودان شكرا لوجودك معنا
مره جديده
نشرت قوته الدعم السريع لقطات فيديو تظهر
انتشار عناصرها في مبنى القصر الجمهوري
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت قوه دعم السريع
انها تسيطر تماما على القصر الجمهوري
ومحيطه في الخرطوم بالاضافه الى مبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون في ام درمان كما اكد
احد قاده الدعم السريع ان سيطرتهم على
القصر الجمهوري تاتي ضمن مساعد دعم السريع
للحفاظ على ثروات الشعب السودانيه
والدعم السريع من داخل القصر الجمهوري نود
ان نوصل رساله
لشعبنا الكريم ولشرفاء القوات المسلحه
اولا
نناشد كل الشرفاء في قوات الشعب المسلح
بان هذا العمل الذي زجت فيه القوات
المسلحه هو عمل يخدم افراد واشخاص محددين
في القوات المسلحه والغرض الاساسي منه
النازل دارين السولو على سلطه الشعب
السوداني وعن طريق كوميتو نحن الان في
قوات الدعم السريع بالناشد كل القوات
المسلحه وشرفاء القوات المسلحه بانه نحنا
بالنسبه لهم وانما نحن نريد ان نحافظ على
سلطه الشعب ونقول للشعب السوداني تواجد
قوات الدعم السريع في داخل القصر وفي كل
ولايه الخرطوم القرض الاساسي منه الحفاظ
على سلطه الشعب
[موسيقى]
حصل الليله في الفردوس هما لكن بس مرقنا
مع
نادينا النار مشتعله في البيت ما معروف
مصدره
والحمد لله شعب السوداني شعبي يعني متقاتل
نحمد الله ونشكر يعني النهارده طلعت سبحان
الله ما معروف من اي جهه يعني
[موسيقى]
ينضموا الينا من الخرطوم الان مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك معنا سالم
ما الذي يحصل الان عندك في العاصمه ما
الذي تراه وتسمعه
نعم ما نراه الان انقطاع لتيار الكهربائي
في العديد من احياء مدينه الخرطوم وبعض
الاحياء في مدينه بحري وام درمان كذلك
لقطاع التيار الكهربائي قبله كان هنالك
اخر النهار هذه الهجمه التي كانت من
القوات الجويه السودانيه وهي هجمه مركزه
بحسب وصف العديد من المراقبين الذين
يتابعون المشهد السوداني لانها كانت لفتره
طويله وكانت ربما تكون هي الاطول منذ بدا
هذه الاشتباكات على مناطق متفرقه من
المناطق التي تتمركز بها قوات الدعم
السريع والتي ظل الجيش السوداني يقول انه
يستهدف مواقعها ومعسكراتها بسلاح الجو
وهذا السلاح تم استخدامه اليوم
بعنف على مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم
ابرزها هنا في الخرطوم محيط مطار الخرطوم
وكذلك محيط القياده العامه للجيش وابرزها
كذلك في ام درمان لدعوه التلفزيون ذلك
المناطق القريبه من هذه المناطق منها جسر
شنبات الرابط بين بحري وام درمان والذي
بالقرب منه معسكر المظلات وهو احد
المعسكرات التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع وقد
قال الدعم السريع من قبل ان الجيش
السوداني قد يستهدف الوحده الموجوده في
المظلات وهي وحده الوحده العلاجيه او
المستشفى العلاج التابع للقوات الدعم
السريع الذي تعالج في هذه القوات جنودها
انه تم استهدافها من السلاح الطبي
بامدرمان وهو ايضا مستشفى عسكريه بعد
القوات المسلحه السودانيه في تبادل هذه
الاتهامات جاءتها جاء هذا القصف الذي
استهدف هذه المناطق المتفرقه من العاصمه
الخرطه ولكن هل يمكن الحديث عن اي بوادر
حسم لاي طرف من الطرفين في اي جهه كانت من
مناطق الاشتباكات او هل يمكن رصد تغير ما
في موازين القوى عند كل طرف من طرفي
الصراع
يمكن الحديث عن ذلك اذا نزلنا الى الارض
وراينا ذلك لكن ما رايناه اليوم على الاقل
في تقديرنا للساعتين والثلاث ساعات ربما
تكون هنالك الكفه للقوات المسلحه بالنظر
لهذه الهجمه التي كانت شرسه وكانت قوات
الدعم السريع حريصه بالرد بالمضادات
الارضيه لكنها لم تفلح بهذه المضادات وظلت
هذه الطائرات تركز ضرباتها مره تلو الاخرى
ربما يكون لهذه الضربه يعني ربما تكون هي
الاولى في موازين القوه في ترجيح واحده من
الكف التابعه للقوات الدعم للقوات الجيش
السوداني كيف يفهم اهل الخرطوم يعني
العلاقه في الصراع بين ما يحدث عندهم وما
حدث في دارفور ومصادر العربيه اتحدثت قبل
قليل عن الاتفاق على توقيع اتفاقيه لوقف
او وثيقه
للهدنه بين الط رفين هناك في الجنينه
تحديدا
نعم ليس هنالك علاقه وطيده بين الاثنين
ربما لكل واحد منهما طريقه مختلفه لان
الامر هنا في هذه الحرب هنا في مدينه
الخرطوم العاصمه يختلف تماما عما يدور في
الجنينه الامر هنا يتعلق بحسب ان وجهه نظر
الطرفين اذا نظرنا الى وجهه نظر القوات
المسلحه السودانيه بان هذا التهديد للدوله
السودانيه وانناؤه بهذا الفعل ربما تنتهي
هذه الدوله الى دويلات وان هذا هو تهديد
لمسار تاريخي لدوله لها تاريخ ولها وزن
وفي المنظوره الاخر قوات الدعم السريع ترى
ان هذا استلاب ايضا للدوله السودانيه عكس
ما يجري في الجنينه في انه صنف بانه صراع
اهلي بين
مختلف مكونات تلك المنطقه لكن ربما اذا
استمرت الاحداث بهذا الشكل وهذا ما يراه
مراقبون كذلك ان تنعكس الاحداث
من مدينه الجنينه الى الخرطوم وهذا ما
يحذر منه الكثير من المراقبين للمشهد
السوداني والقريبين منه بان استمرار هذه
الحرب قد يجعلها تسير الى الحرب الاهليه
وهذه هي الكارثه شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم
مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي تحياتي اليك
الان هذا طمع صوت صاروخ على ماي
[موسيقى]
المدفع
يه
ثقيله واضحه هنا
قوه الشعب المسلحه
نسمع الان بوضوح
منطقه
تحديد الموقع
حنا تقريبا حوالي 3000 4000 5000 العدد
كبير جوا البناء وبرا وعن الكورنيش الناس
تكون في الارض ارامل اطفال مسنين مرضى
احنا قاعدين في الارض ويعني اغلب الناس
قاعدين في الاراضي كلنا جايين اماكن بعيده
اغلبنا اتين من الخرطوم
دخلت عمليات واجلال رعايه دول الاجنبيه من
شرق السودان صوب ميناء جده وعبر مطار
بورتسودان يومها العاشر اكثر من 16 الف
طالب اجلاء غادروا البلاد من خلال شرق
السودان خلال الايام الماضيه غير ان الافا
من السوريين واليمنيين ومقيمين سودانيين
في عدد من الدول العربيه يواجهون صعوبات
في سبيل مغادرتهم السودان
عشره ايام مضت على اول عمليه اجلاء لرعايه
دول الاجنبيه من شرق السودان نحو مختلف
الدول العالم عبر ميناء بورسودان وعبر
مطارها الدولي اكثر من عشرين رحله بحريه
تمت حتى الان ونحو 45 رحله جويه من مطار
بورسودان الدولي تستمر عمليات الاجلاء دون
توقف غير ان اوضاع الرعايه السوريين
المطالبين بجلائهم تشكل استثناء هنا عم
نطلب نروح جده
روح جده وبعدين
نروح اربيل العراق مصر اي اي مكان ما حدا
سال علينا العيال في الشوارع النساء
الشباب مضى معه مصاري هاي ما تصرف الحمد
لله الشعب السوداني ما هو مقصر ابدا لا من
اكل لا من ملبس لا من ماء
هذا الوضع اضبط الاخرى تشهدها المنافذ نحو
الخارج حيث يواجه السودانيون المقيمون في
عدد من الدول ظروف صعبه يقول كثير منهم ان
اوضاعهم لا تحتمل تاخر اجراءات مغادرتهم
للسودان نحن اننا غرامات اننا زيارات يعني
في ناس
طيب نحاول الحكومه واقفه والبلد واقفه دي
مشكله برضو تاني
وبالناس كل السلطات يا جماعه انه لو في
امكانيه توفر لنا بواخر نحن بحقنا بتذاكر
بنشتري كل السودانيين
مستطيعين انهم يدفعوا حق التذاكر بس ما
موجوده بواخر نحن كسودانيين مقيمين في
السعوديه
والسلطات السعوديه انه يسرعوا في اجراءات
اجلانا من مدينه بورسودان الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لانه عندنا طلبه عندهم
جامعات وعندهن اسر
الشفقانين علوم شديد ولازم يصلون باسرع
وقت
للمواجهات المسلحه ارتدادات مختلفه يامل
كثيرون هنا الا تتمدد لتشمل قطاعات اخرى
نزار البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث
مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
اعلن مسؤول اللاجئين في الامم المتحده
توقعاته بفرار ما يفوق الثمن مئه الف شخص
في السودان من السودان اثر النزاع في
البلاد كما اضاف المسؤوله ان ثلاثه وسبعين
الف شخص فروم متجهين الى دول الجوار وفي
السياق ذاته عبر منسق الامم المتحده لشؤون
الانسانيه عن مخاوفه من امتداد ازمه
السودان الى دول الجوار واعلن المنسق ان
الوضع الانساني في البلاد يتجه الى نحو
كارثيه وان شحنه من الادويه عالقه على
الحدود ولم تدخل السودان بعد
كارثه شامله يتجه اليها الوضع الانساني في
السودان
منسق الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه في
السودان وصف الوضع بالكارثه متخوفا من
امتداد الازمه لدول الجوار
تصريحات داعمه لما سبق ادلى بها مسؤول
اللاجئين في الامم المتحده متوقعا فرار
اكثر من 800 الف شخص من السودان
بالاضافه الى 73 الف شخص لاذو بالفرار الى
دول الجوار
هروب جماعي من المعارك والوضع الصحي
المزري مع استمرار خروج المشافي عن الخدمه
ونقص التجهيزات
بينما تواجه شحنه ادويه من الصحه العالميه
عوائق للدخول الى البلاد
الى ذلك حذر البيت الابيض من امتداد
القتال في السودان الى دول الجوار كما
افاد بان التركيز الاساسي حاليا هو تمديد
الهدنه والوصول الى وقف النهائي لاعمال
العنف وان يضع طرفان سلاح جانبا
ويتجهان الى مفاوضات تفضي لحكومه مدنيه
كما صرح البيت الابيض ان الف مواطن امريكي
غادروا السودان منذ بدايه الصراع وان
الوضع على الارض في السودان متقلب ولا
يسمح بعمليات اجلاء لذلك تم نشر طائرات
لحمايه الامريكيين هناك
اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان عن ارتفاع عدد
قتل الاشتباكات الدائره في البلاد الى 436
شخصا كما اكدت ان عدد المصابين ارتفع الى
ما يزيد عن
2175 شخصا في صفوف المدنيين نقابه الاطباء
السودانيين قالت ايضا ان هناك الكثير من
الاصابات والوفيات غير مشموله في هذه
الحصر بسبب صعوبه الوصول للمستشفيات مضيفه
ان الاشتباكات القبليه في مدينه الجنينه
بولايه غرب دارفور اسفرت عن سقوط 94 قتيلا
مشيره الى ان جميع المستشفيات لا تعمل في
المدينه حتى اللحظه
اكد مدير الاعلام لدى اللجنه دوليه لصليب
الاحمر في السودان للعربيه ان العمل جار
لايصال شحنه المواد الطبيه من بورسودان
الى الخرطوم ودارفور والمدن المتاثره
بالقتال
اول شحنه من المواد الطبيه جاهزه وبدانا
بنقلها ومحاوله ايصارها من بورتسودان الى
الخرطوم ودارفور والمدن المتاثره بالقتال
وهناك ايضا شحنه ثانيه ستكون جاهزه خلال
ايام نتوقع ايضا وصول الافراد لتقديم
المساعدات واعتقد باننا اصبحنا جاهزين
ومعنا المتطوعون من الهلال الاحمر
السوداني لكننا بحاجه الى ضمانات امنيه من
الاطراف المتقاتله لنتمكن من الوصول الى
المناطق المتاثره بالقتال
معنى من لندن عبر سكايب دكتوره منال مهدي
عضو نقابه اطباء السودان بالخارج اهلا بك
معنا دكتوره هل هناك اي تحديث على هذه
المعلومات التي ذكرناها للتو
اشتباكات جاريه لليوم السادس
عشر اندلاء الحرب في السودان بين القوات
العسكريه
الدعم السريع ارتفع عدد الوفيات الى اكثر
من 400 اصابه
وكذلك عدد اهرباءات قتيل 400 نحن تحدثنا
عن 436 قتيل وفقا للنقاب السوداني
حاله اصابه
ولكن وزاره الصحه تتهمكم بانكم يعني لستم
على درايه كافيه او قدره كافيه بحصر اعداد
القتلى والجرحى الى ما يعود ذلك لا
تو
اجهنا ما في طرق مؤمنه لوصوله للمستشفيات
نحن في اشد القلق على زملائنا الاطباء لما
يواجهون من في المستشفيات من عدم امان
ويتم نهب
واخلاء المستشفيات بالقوه طبعا وضع خطير
للغايه ولكن وزاره الصحه تتهمكم بتضخيم
الامر والتهويل والتخويف بخصوص وضع البلاد
لاستشفائي والطب والصحي
ابدا ان ابدا هذا ما يحدث على ارض الواقع
والمطعمه ساوي هذه الارقام التي
بطرفكم وطرفنا
هذه ارقام
يخلوه تخلو من حظر كثير كثير من الحالات
التي لم اتصل حتى المستشفيات او لم يتم
حصرها المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في نشره
سابقه معي قال ليس هناك شيء اسمه نقابه
الاطباء بشكل
شرعي ليس هناك جسم الاوكيان اسمه نقابه
الاطباء في السودان من انتم
ولكن نحن
نقابه الاطباء جسم لنا
تكويننا ولنا اعمالنا
ولهم وقفات منذ الوقفات الاحتجاجيه
للسلميه الاولى والى الان وما زالت
النقابه مواصله جهودها ولولا جهود النقابه
وتواصلها مع
[تصفيق]
الاخوه الاطباء على ارض الوطن
لما تمكن لما تمكنوا من وصول
اييي دعم من الخارج
مع وزاره الصحه او ما مشكله وزاره الصحه
معكم بالاحرى ايضا
وزاره الصحه ايضا
تعاني من تقلب السياسات والنزاعات
التي تحصل في السودان ما هي الا
انعكاسات لما يحدث من كل هذه الخلافات على
الحكومه انتم المتهمون بالتسييس بالتسييس
الامور من قبل وزاره الصحه يقولون انكم
تقولون بهذه الارقام وتحاولون ان تصوروا
الوضع على انه بهذه الحاله الماساويه
والمزريه فقط لاسباب سياسيه ليس اكثر وهو
ليس كذلك على بحقيقه الامر
لا يمكنهم نكران ما يحدث على ارض الواقع
لان هذه حقائق ولو
لن يقدروا ان يتغاضوا عنها فكل السوشيال
ميديا هنالك حقائق ثابته بالفيديوهات
وبالتوثيق
وهذه الاحصائيات ليست عبثيا كما هي الحال
وحال حربهم الذي تعبث بارواح المواطنين
هل
المعلومات التي قدمت عن وضع المستشفيات
يعني من نصدق هنا في حال في موضوع
المستشفيات هل هناك مستشفيات فعلا تعمل
وهي كافيه كما تقول وزاره الصحه للعربيه
قبل في نشره سابقه او كما تقولون انتم بان
الوضع ماساوي ولا يعني يعني القطاع لا
تقوم له قائمه الان
لا المستشفيات ينقصها الكادر الطبي الان
لعدم توفر الممرات الامنه وعدم توفر
الكادر الصحي ومنهم
ما زال به ارض الوطن ومنهم مخرج عن ارض
الوطن المستشفيات ينقصها الامكانيات
تنقصها الادويه
ابسط
الادويه والعلاجات والمحاليل الوريديه غير
موجوده
الاسعافات الاوليه التي تقدم في بعض
المستشفيات التي ما زالت تعمل تعمل بصوره
ضئيله جدا جدا اكثر من 60 مستشفى من اصل
86 مستشفى بالعاصمه
والاقاليم غير
متوقفه تماما عن العمل
طرفا بعينه باحتلال المستشفيات
يعني التعرض للطاقم الطبي والصحي في
البلاد
الحرب هي بين الطرفي النزاع هي ما ادى الى
هذا الوضع الماساوي والكارسي ولذلك نقابه
الاطباء وكل مواطن سوداني خارج البلاد
وداخل البلاد حاليا ينادي ويناشد
الانسانيه
بايقاف الحرب فورا حتى يتمكن المواطن من
ايجاد ابسط مقومات الحياه اليوميه من
الشرب وعلاج شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور دكتوره
منال مهدي عضو نقابه اطباق السودان
بالخارج عبر سكايب تحياتي اليك من لندن
استطلعت العربيه راس سودانيين على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه قرروا العوده الى
بلادهم من مصر الى السودان رغم استمرار
الحرب بيقولوا الوضع بقى احسن شويه واحنا
شايفين في قنوات اجتماعي ان الوضع حسن
ويعني ما فيش مشاكل دلوقتي يعني ما فيش
حاجه يعني فعشان كده اضطرينا ان نرجع
بلدنا يعني انا مش خايفه انا اللي عليا مش
خايفه
وهي مشكله انا بحتر لانها هي دي مشكله ما
بين شخصين
عشرون الف لاجئ سوداني يعانون مراره
اللجوء في تشاد اغلبيته من النساء
والاطفال منهم من يعاني من امراض تنفسيه
خطيره غير ان اليونيسف حذرت من البقاء في
قريه كفرون تشاديه خوفا من موسم الامطار
المقبل
خطا نهايتها عصيه طريق اللجوء يطول وصلنا
وحدات الى تشاد لاجئه سودانيه دون مواعيد
بعضهن تمكنا من الدفع فقل عليهن عبء
الطريق نساء واطفال هربوا من حرب اشتعلت
فجاه خيار اللجوء لا مفر منه ضمن حرب
بحصيله كبيره للقتله هرب البيوت وقد قتلوا
ثلاثه نفر اربعه كده عشان كذا
استقروا هنا على الحدود التشاديه
السودانيه كبرات السن لم تعد لهن القدره
على المضي بينما الاطفال اغلبهم يعانون من
امراض تنفسيه وسوء تغذيه
20 الف لاجئ سوداني استقروا في قريه كفرون
تشاديه قريه تفتقر لاساسيات الحياه وضروره
تغيير المكان باتت حتميه
اذا فشلنا في التحرك الان سيفوت الاوان
سياتي موسم الامطار قريبا واذا لم نقدم
مساعده للناس سيتم اغلاق الطريق وسيظل
اللاجئون عالقين هنا
يبدو ان البقاء هنا طويل مخيم اللجوء باتت
تتشكل ملامحه عشرات الاسقف واعمده علها
تشد بيت لاجئ الى حين عوده غيداء السالم
العربيه
ينضم الينا من لندن خالد الاعصار الصحفي
السوداني اهلا بك معنا استاذ خالد الى ما
تعزو عوده الاشتباكات اليوم بعد الهدوء
النسبي امس رغم تمديد الهدنه
لنشاركنا الكرام بالتاكيد دعوه الاشتباكات
هي تمثل حاله من التصاعد العنف الذي
ابتدرته قوات الدعم السريع بمحاوله ادخال
عدد من المركبات الى الخرطوم ليله امس
وتصدت لها القوات المسلحه وبالتاكيد
الاعلان عن الهدن واصبح ياخذ شكلا تكتيكيا
تعلن الهدنه وما تعلن الهدنه واذا بهناك
اختراقات في سياق يعني الحصول على
امتدادات عسكريه
وتحسين المواقف على تحسين المواقف على
الارض وبالتالي
الجيش بضرب مواقعها وتتهمه بالتالي بخرق
الهدنه وليس هي من تتحمل المسؤوليه وحدها
كما تقول
بالتاكيد يصعب التاكيد على المزاعم من
الطرفين بكل تاكيد ولكن الشواهد التي
تثبت الفيديوهات التي يبثها الجيش وتصر
عدد من المركبات التي تحاول دخول الخرطوم
او درمان من جهات مختلفه هذا يثبت الروايه
الارجح وهي روايه الجيش الذي يدلل بمشاهد
حيها سواء كان من تصوير عبر الدرونات او
حتى تصوير من على بعد طيب بغض النظر عن
هذا التضارب الان يبدو في توجه لمحادثات
فنيه كيف يمكن فهم مصطلح محادثات فنيه بين
الطرفين
انا في تقدير ان هذه المحادثات الفنيه هي
تحدد شكل
المفاوضات وربما تدفع باتجاه وقف هذه
الحرب ولكن هذه هذه المفاوضات ايضا تحتاج
الى وضع قضايا اساسيه في طاوله التفاوض
على راسها وقف اطلاق النار بصوره دائمه ثم
القبول بمبدا دمجات الدعم السريع بعد هذا
النزيف وهذا الدمار الذي حل بالبنيه
التحتيه والتقريب الذي الذي اثبت بما لا
يدعم مجال للشكل ان وجود قوتين عسكريتين
في الدوله مهدد امني خطير وليس بعده تهديد
هذا يتطلب القبول بفكره او قرارات التي
اصدار القائد العام للقوات المسلحه والتي
تطالب بدمج القوات وهو بالفعل اصدر قرارات
دمج القوات
وكذلك على صعيد الواقعه الذي تشكل
العمليات العسكريه اصبح قد اصبحت قضيه
الدمج شبه واقع في عدد من الولايات كبير
17 ولايه والذي تبقى في الخرطوم هو قدرات
محدوده لجي عسكريه وهذا يتطلب التعقل من
الطرف الاخر بضروره حقن الدماغ والحفاظ
على روحه الشباب الصغار الذين زج بهم في
معركه غير متكافئه مع قوات مسلحه لديها
تراكم طويل من الحروب والسيالات والخبرات
وهذا فيه نوع من يعني عدم الاهتمام للكادر
البشري وهذه خسائر كبيره للشعب السوداني
ايا كان القتلى في الطرفين وهذه ايضا تقول
حضرتك قوات الدعم السريع اليوم فقط قالت
قبل قليل فقط قالت انه سيكون لنا عوده الى
الاتفاق الاطاري ولكن بعد دحر او استسلام
قياده قوات المسلحه
هو انا في تقديريا للاتفاق بشكل القديم
اصبح ضرب من دروب الماضي لا يمكن ان يكون
سبب الفتنه والحرب الاهليه الحرب العسكريه
او هي ليست اهليه بالطبع هي الحرب
العسكريه بين الفريقين وهذا الاصطفاف وهذا
الدمار الذي حل بالبنيه التحتيه كله يربط
بهذا الاتفاق الايطالي الجزئي الذي اختار
ان يخصص امتيازات لفئه محدده وحصر ما عرف
ببند بمعارف باتفاق اطرافه الاتفاق يصبح
الفكره انه لابد من وجود اتفاق سياسي اي
نعم ولكن لا يمكن العوده الى اسباب الفتنه
التي تفسد الاتفاق الاطار هذه قضيه توافق
حول الرايه العامه السوداني كله لانه
الاتفاق الاطاري ضم ثلاثه احزاب صغيره او
حزبين صغيرين وحزب الامه حزب التجمع
الاتحادي هذا لم يحدث ان دخل تجربه
ديمقراطيه ولم ينتقب ولم نسمع له جميع
عموميه اصلا هذه اشخاص معروفه راح يعطونها
في بريطانيا واثنين في الخرطوم واحد من
امريكا وحزب الاخر هو المؤتمر السوداني
الذي لم يدخل تجربه انتخابيه هل يعقل في
هذه الدوله السودان الراسخه فيها القيمه
الديمقراطيه منذ عشرات السنين ان يتصيد
المسرح فيها هؤلاء الاشخاص لكي يعتبروا او
يامروا الشعب السوداني لكي يستجيب
لنداءاتهم وتعليماتهم والصرف الذي كانوا
يمارسونه في الاطراف التي نطالبديه
اطالب بكل بكل الثوار الذين خاضوا ثوره
ديسمبر وغاهموا الانغاز قبل ان تظهر هذه
الاحزاب المشهوريه الصغيره وطالب بالحركات
المسلحه التي رفعت محمد السلاح لعقود من
الزمان وطالب بالامه السودانيه جمعاء ما
عدا اولئك الذين تورطت اياديهم بارتكاب
جرائم جدا انسانيه او جرائم في تتصل
بالفساد ونهب المال العام او لديهم قضايا
في المحاكم ما دون ذلك السودان وطن للجميع
بعد هذه الحرب يجب ان تسير مسيره التصحيح
في التراك المطلوب وهو ان السودان وطن
لجميع ابناء السودان وليس للمجندين من
خارج السودان هذه جزئيه مهمه السودان وطن
لكل ابناء السودان وليس المجندين من خارج
السودان لن يكون هناك حل اذا كان دائما
اذا كانت دائما المعادله اما تكون يعني مع
طرف بعينه مهما كانت توجهاته السياسيه في
الداخل والا انت عميل للخارج يعني هذه
المعادله قائمه في عدد من الدول العربيه
للاسف ولكنها لا تبني اوطانا
وكيف لمن يريد ان يبني وطنا ويتحدث عن
الديمقراطيه ونشر قيم الديمقراطيه عبر
فوات البنادق ومن يؤيدونه في الاحزاب
الانتهازيه ان يصنف كل من يدعو الى نصره
الجيش الوطني الذي اسس بدستور وقانون منذ
100 عام ان لا يصطف مع جيش الوطن ويصطفى
الى مجموعه عسكريه يراد لها ان تكون مخلب
غض وزراعه عسكري في فتره ديمقراطيه ويصنف
هذا بانه فلول او اسلامي او اسلامويين
كلما يدعم الجيش السوداني عندها في قاموس
وطني ولا علاقه مش لازم تواجه سؤال للجيش
نفسه لقيادات الجيش تتهم بانها هي التي
كبرت هذه القوات وهي التي اعطتها المسافه
والمساحه لكي تتمول وتتسلح
نحن كنا ننتقد دائما قيادات الجيش وموازنه
انها تحت المجال واسعا لقوه عسكريه خارج
مظله المؤسسه العسكريه لتنمو وتكبر خصما
على حساب المؤسسه العسكريه ولكن في ذات
الوقت نحن نرفض فكره الخروج عن امره
المؤسسه العسكريه وتعليمات القائد العام
ومحاوله احتلال المطارات وحرق الطائرات
وتفكير بالاسري وترضى من بيوتا واطلاق
سراح السجناء انا لست على خلاف مع الدعم
السريع ارى فيه امكانيه ان يصبح الجيش
مساعد للامه السودانيه كما اريد له ولكن
الحديث عن الفلول وعن القيادات الاسلاميه
والله انا احلف لك عليها يعني لا يوجد جسم
يدلل على الفلول والنظام الاسلاموي
وللاسلام يسميه كما يسمونه ام الاسلام
هنسميه الاسلامي والحركه الاسلاميه
والمؤتمر الوطني اكثر من الدعم السريع
الذي اسسوا البشير هذا جسم تاسس وتربى
وتدمر كل الدم اللي يجري فيه في جسمه وفي
جسده هو من صلب الحركه الاسلاميه
من كل هذا صحيح اتهامات لكن حتى
بين الطرفين نعم نفس الاتهامات متبادله
البشير البشير البشير يقول ان جيش الدعم
السريع هو جيش هو حمايه ويسميه حمايه وليس
حمايتي هذا البشير رئيس التنظيم الاسلامي
الذي حكم السودان ولم يقول الجيش بل انشا
هذا التنسيق التنظيم ليحميه من الجيش اذا
الجيش والجسم الوطني الذي تتعدد فيه
المكونات الوطنيه العرقيه والحزبيه وكل
الانتماء تمام يعني نكون منصفين بين
الطرفين ايضا قوات الدعم السريعه تتهم بعض
قيادات الجيش بالانتماء الى الحركه
الاسلاميه وبمحاوله احياء النظام السابق
شكرا جزيلا لك خالد الاعسر الصحفي
السوداني من لندن تحياتي اليك اشكرك
والله هذا يعني شعور لا يوصف انه الواحد
يكون كله يعني هو والاسره كلهم بامان
الناس كثيره هناك عندها مشاكل ما قادره ما
عندها فلوس ما عندها مصاري ناس كتير معلقه
نحمد الله سبحانه وتعالى والشكر لاهل
المملكه هل هذا الاستق
[موسيقى]
وصلت سفينه جلاله الملك ابها الى مدينه
جده وهي تحمل واحد واربعين مواطنا سعوديا
ومئه وواحد وسبعين من رعايه دول اخرى
وذكرت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان عدد
الرعايه الذين تم اجلائهم من السودان حتى
الان يفوقوا 5000 شخص من بينهم 225 مواطنا
سعوديا والبقيه من مئه وجنسيه
في مشهد مؤثر لعمليه اجلاء نقل افراد من
البحريه السعوديه شابا من ذوي الاعاقه من
مدينه من ميناء بورتسودان الى سطح سفينه
جلاله الملك الدرعيه المتجهه الى جده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العربيه الثاني
عن شكلها للقوات المسلحه السعوديه
لمساهمتها ودعمها جهود اجلاء مئات
المواطنين الامريكيين من السودان الى جده
وقال قائد القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
مايكل كوريلا انه عبر خلال اتصال هاتفي
برئيس الاركان السعوديه فياضر ويلي عن
تقديره وشكره لسماح السعوديه بفتح قواعدها
ومجالها البحري والجوي لتامين وصول مئات
المواطنين الامريكيين بامان الى جده ومن
ثم القيام باجلائهم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات